여러분, 마트에서 바나나를 살 때 이런 생각을 해보신 적 있으신가요?
왜 바나나는 어디서 사도 거의 비슷할까요?
사과는 빨간 사과도 있고, 초록 사과도 있고, 단단한 사과도 있는데
바나나는 대부분 길쭉하고, 노랗고, 익으면 달고 부드럽습니다.
너무 익숙해서 이상하게 느끼지 못할 뿐이지
사실 바나나는 꽤 특이한 과일입니다.
이 비슷함은 우연이 아닙니다.
우리가 흔히 먹는 바나나는 대부분 캐번디쉬 계열이고
씨앗을 심어 키우기보다 기존 식물에서 나온 새순을 다시 심는 방식으로 재배됩니다.
쉽게 말해서 비슷한 바나나를 계속 복사해서 키워온 겁니다.
이렇게 하면 맛과 크기를 예측하기 쉽고 대량 생산도 편합니다.
소비자도 언제 사도 익숙한 바나나를 먹을 수 있습니다.
그런데 바로 이 장점이 약점이 되기도 합니다.
넓은 지역에서 거의 같은 바나나를 키우고 있다면
그 품종을 공격하는 병이 나타났을 때
피해가 한 농장으로 끝나지 않을 수 있습니다.
바나나 몇 구류가 시드는 문제가 아니라
전 세계 공급망의 문제가 될 수 있는 겁니다.
원래 바나나는 지금처럼 먹기 쉬운 과일이 아니었습니다.
야생 바나나에는 단단한 씨가 많았고
과육도 지금처럼 부드럽지 않았습니다.
하지만 사람들은 오랜 시간 동안 더 달고 더 부드럽고
씨가 적은 바나나를 골라 제외했습니다.
그 결과 우리가 아는 씨 없는 바나나가 널리 퍼지게 된 겁니다.
문제는?
여기서부터입니다.
씨가 거의 없다는 것은 먹기에는 편하지만
씨앗을 심어 다음 세대를 만들기 어렵다는 뜻이기도 합니다.
그래서 바나나는 보통 씨앗이 아니라
식물 밑에서 나오는 새순을 떼어내 다시 심는 방식으로 재배됩니다.
이렇게 하면 원래 식물과 거의 같은 바나나가 자라게 되죠.
농업적으로는 매우 효율적인 방식입니다.
맛과 크기를 일정하게 만들 수 있고
소비자가 좋아하는 바나나를 대량으로 키울 수 있습니다.
하지만 바나나들이 서로 너무 비슷해지면
병에 대한 반응도 비슷해질 수 있습니다.
어떤 병이 한 품종을 공격할 수 있다면
그와 비슷한 바나나들이 한꺼번에 위험해질 수 있다는 겁니다.
이게 오늘 이야기의 핵심입니다.
바나나는 너무 성공적으로 표준화됐고
그 표준화가 병 앞에서는 약점이 될 수 있습니다.
그렇다면 바나나는 어떻게 세계적인 과일이 됐을까요?
단순히 맛있어서만은 아닙니다.
전 세계 시장에서 팔리려면 맛뿐만 아니라
멀리 보낼 수 있어야 하고 대량으로 키울 수 있어야 하며
운송 중에 쉽게 상하지 않아야 합니다.
바나나는 이 조건에 매우 잘 맞았습니다.
초록색일 때 수확해서 배에 싣고 먼 나라로 보낸 뒤
시장에 도착할 무렵 익혀서 팔 수 있었습니다.
껍질이 과육을 보호해주고 소비자는 별도 조리 없이 바로 먹을 수 있었습니다.
결국 세계 시장에서는 다양한 맛을 가진 바나나보다
잘 키울 수 있고 잘 운송할 수 있고
일정하게 팔 수 있는 바나나가 중요해진 겁니다.
그리고 한때 그 역할은
바로 그로미셸입니다.
지금 우리가 마트에서 보는 바나나는 대부분 캐번디시지만
20세기 초반 세계 수출 시장의 주인공은 그로미셸이었습니다.
그로미셸은 크기도 좋고 맛도 좋았고
껍질이 비교적 두꺼워서 운송 중에 상처가 덜 났습니다.
당시에는 지금처럼 냉장 물류가 정교하지 않았기 때문에
먼 나라까지 보내도 쉽게 망가지지 않는 품종이 중요했습니다.
문제는 너무 많은 농장에서 그로미셸을 대신하는 것입니다.
대량으로 키우기 시작했다는 점입니다.
하나의 품종이 산업의 중심이 되면 생산과 유통은 효율적입니다.
하지만 그 품종을 공격하는 병이 들어오면
피해도 빠르게 커질 수 있습니다.
실제로 그로미셸은 파나마 병이라고 불리는
푸사리움 시드름병에 큰 타격을 받았습니다.
이 병은 흙 속에 사는 곰팡이가 원인입니다.
곰팡이는 바나나 뿌리로 들어가
식물 안쪽에서 물과 영양분이 이동하는 통로를 막습니다.
처음에는 겉으로 멀쩡해 보일 수 있지만
시간에 따라서는 곰팡이가 더욱 커질 수 있습니다.
이 병은 흙 속에 사는 곰팡이가 원인입니다.
시간이 지나면 잎이 노랗게 변하고 식물 전체가 약해집니다.
더 큰 문제는 이 병이 흙에 오래 남는다는 점입니다.
감염된 흙은 농기계나 신발, 물길을 따라 이동할 수 있고
겉으로 멀쩡해 보이는 새순으로 옮겨 심는 과정에서도
다른 지역으로 퍼질 수 있습니다.
결국 그로미셸 중심의 바나나 산업은 큰 압박을 받았습니다.
감염된 땅을 포기하고 새로운 땅을 찾아야 했지만
이런 방식은 오래 유지되기가 어려웠습니다.
그래서 세계 바나나 시장의 중심에 등장한 품종이
바로 캐번디시였습니다.
캐번디시가 선택된 이유도 단순히 가장 맛있어서가 아니었습니다.
가장 중요한 이유는 당시 그로미셸을 무너뜨렸던 병에
비교적 잘 버텼기 때문입니다.
물론 처음부터 완벽한 품종은 아니었습니다.
그로미셸보다 껍질이 약하다는 평가도 있었고
운송 중 상처가 생기기 쉬운 문제도 있었습니다.
그래서 상자 포장과 조심스러운 운송이 더 중요해졌습니다.
하지만 시간이 지나면서 농장, 포장, 유통, 소비자의 기대가
모두 캐번디시에 맞춰졌습니다.
결국 캐번디시는 오늘날 바나나의 표준이 됐습니다.
크기가 비슷하고 맛이 비슷하고 가격도 비교적 저렴한 바나나
우리가 익숙하게 생각하는 그 모습은 자연스럽게 생긴 결과라기보다
재배와 유통이 한 품종을 중심으로 맞춰진 결과였습니다.
여기까지 들으면 문제가 해결된 것처럼 보입니다.
그로미셸이 병에 약해서 캐번디시로 바꿨고
우리는 지금까지 잘 먹고 있으니까요.
그런데 다시 문제가 생겼습니다.
이번에는 캐번디시를 공격할 수 있는
TR4가 퍼지고 있습니다.
TR4는 푸사리움 시드름병의 한 종류입니다.
이름은 복잡하지만 핵심은 간단합니다.
과거의 병이 그로미셸을 밀어냈다면
이번 TR4는 지금의 주류 품종인 캐번디시에도 피해를 줄 수 있다는 겁니다.
이 병도 뿌리로 들어가 식물 안쪽의 물기를 방해하고
한 번 흙에 자리 잡으면 없애기가 어렵습니다.
그래서 TR4는 치료보다 예방이 중요합니다.
농장 안으로 들어오지 못하게 맞고 들어왔다면
다른 지역으로 퍼지지 않게 관리해야 합니다.
농기계, 작업자의 신발, 물길, 묘목 이동까지 신경 써야 합니다.
아주 작은 흙이나 감염된 식물 조각만 이동해도
문제가 커질 수 있기 때문입니다.
TR4는 이미 아시아 여러 지역에서 큰 피해를 줬습니다.
그런데 세계 바나나 산업이 특히 긴장하는 지역은 따로 있죠.
바로 라틴 아메리카입니다.
이유는 단순합니다.
세계에서 수출되는 바나나의 많은 부분이
이 지역에서 나오기 때문이죠.
특히 에카도르는
에카도르는 전 세계에서 수출되는 바나나의 많은 부분이 이 지역에서 나오기 때문이죠.
세계 바나나 공급망에서 매우 중요한 나라입니다.
이런 지역에서 문제가 생기면
단순히 한 농장의 피해로 끝나지 않습니다.
수출량, 가격, 농장 일자리, 포장시설, 항만 물류까지 영향을 받을 수 있고
결국 소비자가 마트에서 보는 바나나 가격이나
공급에도 영향을 줄 수 있습니다.
실제로 TR4는 2019년 콜롬비아에서 라틴 아메리카 첫 사례가 확인됐고
이후 페루 등에서도 보고됐습니다.
그리고 2025년에는 에카도르에서도 관련 사례가 확인되면서
바나나 산업의 긴장을 받을 수 있습니다.
바나나 산업의 긴장감이 더 커지고 있습니다.
물론 이것이 곧바로 전 세계 바나나 공급이 멈춘다는 뜻은 아닙니다.
그렇게 말하면 과장이죠.
하지만 TR4는 한 번 퍼지면 관리가 어렵고
오염된 땅을 다시 정상적으로 쓰기도 쉽지 않습니다.
그래서 주요 수출국에서 감염 사례가 나왔다는 것만으로도
산업 전체에는 민감한 신호가 됩니다.
그렇다면 해결책은 없을까요?
크게 보면 두 가지입니다.
하나는 병이 들어오지 못하게 막는 방역입니다.
다른 하나는
TR4에 더 잘 버티는 바나나 품종을 찾는 겁니다.
실제로 대만과 호주 등에서는
저항성 바나나 연구가 진행되어 왔습니다.
다만 품종하다가 나온다고 문제가 바로 끝나는 것은 아닙니다.
새 바나나는 병에 강해야 할 뿐만 아니라
농민이 키우기 쉬워야 하고 수확량도 충분해야 하고
소비자가 맛과 식감을 받아들여야 합니다.
먼 거리 운송에도 버틸 수 있어야 하고
가격도 지나치게 높으면 안 됩니다.
바나나는 단순히 살아남기만 하면 되는 식물이 아니라
전세계 시장에서 계속 팔릴 수 있는 상품이어야 합니다.
물론 캐번디쉬가 당장 사라지지는 않을 겁니다.
하지만 TR4가 계속 퍼지면 생산비용은 올라갈 수 있고
일부 지역에서는 재배가 어려워질 수 있습니다.
오늘 이야기가 중요한 이유는
이것이 단지 과일 하나의 문제가 아니기 때문입니다.
우리가 먹는 많은 식품은 더 싸게, 더 많이,
더 일정하게 공급되기 위해 표준화되어 왔습니다.
소비자에게는 편리하지만
다양성이 줄어든 시스템은 특정한 병이나
환경 변화가 닥쳤을 때 선택지가 좁아질 수 있습니다.
바나나는 그 문제를 가장 쉽게 보여주는 사례입니다.
세계에서 가장 성공적으로 상품화된 과일 중 하나였지만
바로 그 성공 때문에 하나의 병이
산업 전체의 문제가 될 수도 있습니다.
커피, 카카오, 감자, 밀, 쌀 같은 작물도
비슷한 질문을 던집니다.
우리는 어떤 품종에 얼마나 의존하고 있을까요?
그 품종이 병이나 기후변화에 약해지면
우리의 식탁은 얼마나 영향을 받을까요?
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.